- Les soldats ukrainiens dans
les tranchées de la première
ligne face à Donetsk, occupée
l'avaient dit : "Nous sommes
prêts pour la contre-offensive
dès que l'ordre sera donné."
à l'offensive près de Kharkiv,s,
et à Izium, sur la ligne
de front de 400 km du Donbass.
Parce qu'alors qu'on
on se rend compte que la poussée
russe dans le ssss
est qualifiée d'anémique.
XAVIER TYTELMAN, consultant
- Sur les sept tentatives
d'assaut a a a a réussi à
documenter, en essayant de faire
la remontée des médias sociaux,t
réussi, avec des avancées, pour
les Russes, qui sont minimes,
qui sont d'un à deux kilomètres
par jour, donc qui sont vraiment
finalement, souvent, ça n'arrive
qu'il y a une contre-offensive
ukrainienne. C'est ce qu'on
(cris)
- Au 75e jour de la guerre,
les Russes n'ont pas beaucicici.
(acclamations)
Alors que les Ukrainiens
se glorifient de la destruction
récente de deux vedeoioioioioio,
ainsi que du croiseur amiral,
Moskva.
Avec aussi des frappes
à l'intérieur dsisisisisie
et la mort de 12 généraux russe
sur le terrain.
- Oui, il y a globalement
un mort toutes les semaines,
un général qui mmamamamamamamamt
simplement représentatif
de ce qui se passe tout en bas
également. On a maintenant
réussi à drtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtr0
blindés, 3500 blindés matériels,
des chars, des tanks, des
systèmes de défense et systèmes
d'artillssssssssssssssssssssssse
armée, comme l'armée française,
qu'ils ont déjà perdus
aujourd'hui.
À côté de ça, on estime qu'il
y a enviroololololololdats
russes qui sont morts,
et environ 30 000 blessés, plus
de prisonniers. Donc, tout ça
faiteseseseseses 150 000,
180 000 hommes qui avaient été
engagés par la Russie, il y en a
aujourd'hui totalement inaptes
E E E E E E Et le problème, c't
que la Russie a déjà engagé
plus de la moitié de son arméeds
de Kiev pourrait-elle se
reproduire dans l'est et le sud?
- Et on a comme l'impression...
Moi, là, le send d d d d d d d t
cette vidéo deux semaines avant
que la Russie renonce à prendre
Kiev. Moi, j'ai l'impression
qu'on est nbnbnbnbnbnbnbnbnbnbnr
de Kharkiv. Les Russes don
l'impression qu'ils sont
dans l'incapacité de contincncnt
des attaques de plus e
fréquentes.
- En attendant, la v
offensive est annoncée par
le conseiller de la présidence,
Oleksiy Arestovych,mimimimimimi.
Le temps de recevoir
familiariser avec le matériel
militaire moderne en
massivement par les alliés.
Alors que les sanctions contre
la Russie ont mis un termeononot
de blindés les plus modernes
fautes de pièces indispensables
venues de l'Ouest. Le tempememer
de l'Ukraine.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Montréa